[music]
Narrator:
Open spaces are natural areas
where development has been set aside. Sometimes known as "green space," an open space could be a forest,
Narrator:
wetland, park or pond.
Dedicated nonprofit groups, like Friends of Princeton Open Space,
Narrator:
are striving to conserve these natural areas in our communities.
Steve Hiltner:
My name is Steve Hiltner. I'm natural resources manager for Friends of Princeton Open Space.
There's a lot of ecological services rendered through open space.
Steve Hiltner:
Well, a big part of it is clean water. The water that runs off this land is
essentially going to be our water supply, our drinking water, x-number of weeks later.
Steve Hiltner:
So, it's really important that the water that's running into these streams is clean.
Narrator:
The waters that flow through these lands support a vibrant ecosystem.
Steve Hiltner:
Biodiversity is having as many different species that have evolved in this area,
and the more different kinds of species you have living in balance with each other,
Steve Hiltner:
the stronger the ecosystem, the more resilient.
Narrator:
These various species live in balance with one another.
Steve Hiltner:
Of course, you have all the insect life that depends on the native plants, and then the birds depend on
those insects for survival, so there's this whole food chain that the
Steve Hiltner:
open space provides a basis for.
Narrator:
But these ecological havens are at risk.
Steve Hiltner:
Through climate change and through habitat loss and so forth, fragmentation of habitat,
you're essentially removing species one at a time, taking them out of the ecosystem
Steve Hiltner:
and making it ever more unstable and vulnerable.
Narrator:
Although open spaces are facing ever-greater threats from human development, human action
can also reverse this trend. We can all conserve open space by getting involved.
Narrator:
Spread awareness of the value of natural areas. Take a walk, hike, jog or just connect with nature.
[music]